لنعرف المزيد ينضم الي من الخرطوم يوسف
عزت مستشار سياسي لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد قوات الدعم السريع اهلا بك سيد يوسف
هل يمكن ان تطلعنا على الوضع الان
وبالنسبه للهدنه هل هناك التزام مئه
بالمئه من قبلكم
نعم نحن نلتزم بالهدنه مع الاحتفاظ بحق
الرد اذا هجمت اي من ارتكازاتنا او
المناطق التي نسيطر عليها نحن التزمنا
بالهدنه والان نمثل عمليا هذه الهدنه نحن
نسيطر على مناطق واسعه جدا في العاصمه
القوميه بمدنها ثلاثه فنحن ننظر الى
الهدنه على اساس انها الهدنه انسانيه يجب
ان يستفيد منها المواطن لان المواطن خلال
الخمسه ايام الماضيه عان كثيرا
مرات امنه لهؤلاء المواطنين لايصال
المعدات مثلا الى المستشفيات حتى يخرج بعض
الطلاب الذين ما زالوا يقبعون في المدارس
والجامعات
[موسيقى]
حمايتهم وحمايه امتلاكاتهم اثناء هذه
الهدنه لان المواطنين لا يجدون على وجوههم
عبر الشوارع لا يجدون اي مكان يشترون منه
منه اي
مواد غذائيه او ادويه يحتاجون اليها هذه
هي المشكله التي تواجهنا الان في المدن
الثلاث عبرك وناشد كل اصحاب البقالات لا
يخافوا الذات في المناطق التي نسيطر عليها
ويفتحوا عدلاتهم بشكل عاجل
لتقديم خدماتهم للمواطنين استاذ يوسف ما
هي المناطق التي ما زلتم تسيطرون عليها
نحن نسيطر على بحري بشكل كامل نسيطر على
الخرطوم على القياده العامه نسيطر على
مطار الخرطوم ونسيطر على امتداد شارع
المطار الى نهايه الازهري نسيطر على شارع
مدني الى كوبري سوبا نسيطر على شانيل بشكل
شبهي كامل نسيطر الاذاعه والتلفزيون مسيطر
على مداخل الكباري شبات
منظم الكباري تحصرتنا هذه كلها المناطق
تقع تحت السيطرتنا درمان ايضا في صالحه في
كل المناطق لدينا قوه كبيره ترتكز هناك
ولدينا انتشار واثق في العاصمه
الاشتباكات اين تتركز استاذ يوسف
يستغل الجيش الهدنه لتحريك
مهاجمه محيط القياده لمحاوله الدخول بعد
عمليات فاشله طيله اليوم هاجم الجيش في
الصباحيه الصغيره
القوات انا داخل القياده العامه قام
بانزال جوي فاشل للاسف تم قتل جميع الذين
تم انزالهم داخل القياده العامه
وهي ارواحها نتمنى ان لا
نفقدها ولكن عمليه متهوره تم تحريك رتله
من الدبابات
لاستعاده الغاز العامه وكلها وحرقه هذه
العمليه تجري الام ايضا محاولات
للقياده العامه الجنود المصريين اسمح لي
ان نسال عن موضوع الجنود المصريين كانت
الاخبار
تقريبا ساعتين تحدثت بانه بعض الجنود
وصلوا الى مصر وانه هناك تنسيق مع السودان
ليصل كل الجنود الى مصر هل يمكن ان تطلعنا
على الجنود الذين كانوا في قاعده مروي وما
هو مصيرها نعم حين سيطره القوات الدعم
السريعه على مروي على قاعده مرويه
تسلمت او سلم لها جنود مصريين هم ليسوا
اسرى لانهم لم يكونوا محاربين ليسوا
رحائل
اتصلت القناه الموجوده بيننا وبين القياده
المصريه اكدنا للقياده المصريه انهم تحت
حمايتنا ومسؤوليتنا
نضمن سلامتهم الى حين يتوفر المناخ
المناسب لتسليمهم الى قيادتهم بعد ان قررت
قياده الدعم السريع لاخلاه قاعده مروي
العسكريه
واستجاب القوه للخرطوم لتعزيز الحرب
الدائره هنا
اخذت القوه مع المصريين وعدم تركهم لاننا
لا نضمن سلامته في الحرب التي في الان وتم
تسليمهم الى الى قيادتهم وتم فتح المطار
الذي يسيطر عليه وهبطت الطائره واخذتهم
الى بلادهم سالمين هذه كل المجموعه
تنسيق مع الجيش ايضا لوصول هؤلاء الجنود
الى الى مصر يعني بيان الجيش تحدث بانه
كانت تنسيق مع الجيش لوصول الجنود الى مصر
لا تنسيق ليس مع الجيش لانه هما نحن الذين
نضمن للقياده المصريه سلامه هؤلاء جنوبهم
معنا اكثر من خمسه ايام موجودين معنا تمت
معاملتهم معامله كريمه الجيش لا يمتلك
سلطه فتح المطار ولكنه قال بانه ينصق مع
الاطراف السودانيه من هي هذه الاطراف انتم
نعم لانه لانه وصول طائره واقلاعها في ظل
حرب يتطلب التنسيق مع كافه الاطراف حتى لا
تتعرض الطائره العين حتى لا يفسر بانها
دعم لطرف من الاطراف يعني هذا الاطراف هي
انتم يعني كان هناك تنسيق بينكم وبين
الجيش في هذه العمليه لا نحن لم ننسق مع
الجيش في هذه العمليه بالكامل
لا يستدعي على الطائر هذه السلطات المصريه
هي التي قامت بذلك التنسيق نحن ليس لديها
اي تنسيق مع الجيش ولا نحتاج لذلك لان
المطار في يدنا والجنود في يدنا
وبرج المراقبه ليعمل فيه يعني استطعنا
الاستجابه يستطيع انزال الطائره بسلام
واغلاقها بسلام وتم تامين كل العمليه من
قبل ان لم يكن هنالك اي تدخل للجيش في
العمليه ولكن السلطات المصريه قد تكون
نفسها مع الجيش
لعدم الاعتداء امام
اطلاق النار مع اي اطلاق نار في اثناء
هبوط الطائره واقلع في المناطق المجاوره
للمطار هذا هذه مساله نحن لست فيها نحن
تنسيقنا بالكامل مع مع المصري
بالنسبه ايضا لهذه الهدنه هي من المفترض
ان تكون لمده 24 ساعه هل هذه الهدنه في
كافه الاقاليم حيث هناك اشتباكات بينكم
وبين الجيش ام فقط في الخرطوم
نحن ننظر للهدنه في كافه الاقاليم لكن في
الاقاليم التي تدور فيها المعارك لا توجد
ازمه انسانيه بالحجم الذي توجد في الخرطوم
بالخرطوم خلال الخمسه ايام عاشت معارك
عنيفه هنالك انقطاع للخدمات هنالك مرضى في
المستشفيات فنحن اليوم نحاول يعني مرضى
حالات طارئه جدا مرده في الاعلان مكثفه
بمستشفى الاكثر من 20 مريت انقطع عنه
الاكسجين لا ادري حتى الان العم على قيد
الحياه املاح حاولنا جهدنا ان نفتح المراه
من وقت المعارك لم نستطيع العبور الى
مستشفى وانقطع الاتصال بيننا وبين الشخص
المناسب لهذه العمليه هنالك حالات طارئه
حالات
تحتاج الى هدنه تحتاج هذه الهدنه هدنه
انسانيه بحته تحتاج الى فتحات عامه
للمواطنين لان المواطنين
هنالك الشحف في كل شيء شحته لكن هناك
اغلاق شيبي للمتاجر هذه الهدنه هذا هو
هدفها
اريد ان اعود لموضوع الجنود المصريين يعني
حسب الاخبار التي وردت منذ ساعتين بان
هناك قسم
وصل الى مصر هل تؤكد لنا هذا الموضوع
وماذا عن الدفعه الثانيه
جنود المصريين نحن الذين سلموا لنا هم
الذين كانوا داخل القاعده لا ندري اذا كان
هنالك جنود اخرين ولكن هؤلاء الذين كانوا
في القاعده هل كلهم وصلوا الى مصر هل يمكن
ان تؤكد لنا ذلك نحن سلمناهم جميعا لا
ندري هل تم
تقسيمهم او احتفظت المصريه هنا بالجزء
منهم ام لا لكن نحن سلمنا الطرف المصري كل
المصريين الذين بيدنا واخلينا كامله من
هذا الامر
استاذ يوسف يعني الان انتم ليس لديكم اي
جندي مصري
لا ليس لدي
ليس كلهم سلمتوهم
لاي جهه سلمتوهم
للسلطات المصريه الموجوده في الخرطوم
طب من اي مطار تم نقل هؤلاء الجنود الى
مصر
عن تفاصيل هذه عمليه دارت وسط وسط قذائف
وسط الحرب تمت عمليه
تسليمهم في مكان عامل تم نقلهم للمطار
بترتيبات معينه هذه عمليه فيها جانب عسكري
فيها
ترتيباتنا مع
السلطات المصريه فهذه عمليه
تمت سياتي اليوم الذي يمكن نتحدث عنها كيف
تمت ومتى والساعه كم ومن تسلم
لنا بان كل الجنود المصريين اصبحوا في مصر
الذين كانوا موجودين في قاعده مروي
انا لا اقول كل الموجودين في قائده مروي
كل الموجودين بيد الدعم السريع هنالك
مساكن للمصريين
انا لا ادري هالشي اخرين ما زالوا في مروي
هل تم نقل الاخرين كلهم الى الخرطوم نحن
نقلناها المجموعه التي بيدنا نقلناها مع
القوات التي تحركت من الخرطوم وتم تسليمهم
مع الدعم السريع يمكن القول بانه تم
تسليمهم بالكامل
اشكرك استاذ يوسف عزت
المستشار السياسي لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد قوات الدعم السريع على المشاركه
معنا وعلى هذه
التفاصيل التي يعني خصيت فيها العربيه
شكرا لك لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات